monsieur caisse asus bonjour merci
d'être en direct avec nous alors voilà
le pays est au ralenti toute activité
non essentiels a cessé en suisse bar
restaurant tout est fermé
comment ce que vous vivez actuellement
la situation relativement bien mais la
suisse a tardé par rapport à d'autres
pays si je fais la comparaison avec la
france
il est clair et net que il ya eu deux
trois jours de retard à l'allumage
alors la raison est simple c'est que le
système médical et le système de santé
suisse est un système fédéral et il
s'avère que le fédéralisme qui peut
avoir beaucoup davantage dans d'autres
domaines et extrêmement contre productif
voire dangereux en matière de santé
c'est à dire que les cantons ont dit non
non c'est notre affaire
sauf que le coronavirus lui s'en fichait
pas mal de savoir qu'il était dans le
combat du zurich de lucerne les grisons
on sait que le gouvernement a donc
interdit tout rassemblement il a même
fait appel à des militaires vie
militaire je crois qu'ils vont être
déployés comment cette situation
est-elle vécue justement par la
population suisse est ce qu'ils suivent
à la lettre
voilà les les mesures qui ont été
déclarés par le gouvernement ne sont pas
dans le cas français ne tombent pas dans
cas espagnol nous ne sommes pas dans le
cas italien du confinement nous sommes
encore dans une position je dirais une
situation intermédiaire la prise de
conscience en suisse était beaucoup plus
faible au beaucoup moins présente
la suisse après l'italie avait le taux
de progression la courbe exponentielle
la plus importante et la presse suisse
on n'a pas parlé moi je n'ai appris en
lisant la presse italienne et en
entendant également d
mais deçà des virologues européen c'est
à dire qu'il n'ya pas eu de prise de
conscience et ceci pose un problème
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui même du côté
suisse on a un peu l'impression en est
un peu à part vous savez la suisse est
un pays qui a d'énormes davantage et des
outils lemay a donc je l'adorent mais il
l'a aussi se défausse sur souvent d'être
un peu comment dirais-je hors des
réalités des pays qui l'entourent et
donc les suit je pensais que le virus
allait s'arrêter à ses frontières ce
n'est pas le cas donc il y as travail
important à faire et lorsque j'écoute
par exemple la division allemande et
surtout les médias français la division
française il ya beaucoup plus
d'informations dans les pays étrangers
notamment en france que ce n'est le
quart en suisse
c'est quoi ça manque de transparence ou
justement vous comme vous venez de le
dire vous êtes à part les suisses
restent un petit peu dans leur bulle ils
ont pas vraiment de prise de conscience
par rapport aux dangers du coronavirus
alors il y a un peu cet esprit d'être à
part de jouer la politique de l'autruche
voire de croire de se croire à l'abri de
tous les ceci remonte à l'histoire par
exemple durant la seconde guerre
mondiale mais il ya aussi je me répète
un problème structurel qui est le
problème du fédéralisme je suis pas un
anti fédéraliste
point barre au contraire je considère
comme fédéraliste peut avoir des
avantages mais au niveau de la politique
de santé haute corse
il ya des cas telle gravité le
fédéralisme a failli et ça les suisses
ne veulent pas l'admettre et une erreur
énorme
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné il
faut savoir qu'il faut un chef qui
organise ce leurre en italie ses côtés
en espagne c'est ça de fès en france et
macro mais là il n'a pas alors le
ministre de l'intérieur qui en même
temps responsable du domaine de santé
alain berset qui d'ailleurs est
fribourgeois a essayé ou fait
merveilleusement son travail mais les
contours lors alors on met on lui a mis
les bâtons dans les roues et donc tout
simplement il n'a pas pu développer sa
politique alors que lui avait raison et
que les comptes on avait tort très bien
en tout cas merci beaucoup monsieur
gilbert casasus de nous avoir éclairé
un sur la situation du corona virus en
suisse je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur en études européennes à
fribourg